What cheer, m'ladies.
I return with libations
as promised.
Thanks, Liam.
Hey, text me later.
I've been saving up some things
I've been meaning
to tell you all day.
Is that your boyfriend?
(bleep) you, no.
Liam's from HelloM'lady.com.
Is that a dating site?
No, it's an app for your
smart phone
that helps you manage
those clingy,
fragile guys
who think they're dating you.
Wait, are they stalkers?
God, no, stalkers have balls.
Hello m'lady's just
make you feel guilty.
They do that thing where
they put you on a pedestal
and they dote on you,
even though you've never
expressed any interest.
But why would I wanna
sign up for that?
Just think of it
like Turbo Tax.
No one wants to do taxes
but it is nice to have help
with that inevitable chore.
Hmm.
Hello m'lady notifies you
of the whereabouts
of m'ladies in your area.
The app alerts you when
you've been selected
by one of these human hobbits.
You'll receive
Cliff Notes versions
of his thesis linked emails
listing the things he sees
in you that no one else sees.
This sad-eyed weasel helped
my boyfriend move into my place.
This doughy munchkin flat out
gave me an iPhone.
He said he had a hook-up,
but I'm pretty sure
he just paid for it.
(text alert sounding)
It's a text from Liam.
"I wish I kissed you just now."
(text alert sounding)
Oh, gross, I was just chosen.
I don't wanna
lead this guy on,
but I don't wanna hurt
his feelings either.
Oh, you can't win.
But the app does send you
a warning text
when he's about
to angrily turn on you.
(text alert)
Warning, m'lady.
Can we talk outside, please?
I think you owe me that much.
It's fine, he's just
gonna call me ungrateful
and then ask if he can
hold my hand.
Oh.
It seems you've been abandoned
and I just wanna say...
...hello, m'lady.
Oh.
Hello m'lady.
(bleep) it.
Hey.
♪